alors même s'il aime votre mari mon mari
mon mari ma dernière fois que j'ai vu
c'était les deux ans et il m'a dit je
reviens je descends les poubelles
iupac là
et mon papa malo
chez moi hein c'est pas des pouvoirs
chez moi trois ans d'études c'est sympa
on m'a dit les poubelles c'est ici à non
pas du tout monsieur annoncé à
l'immeuble à côté de moi je suis un
magasin pour guy sémon en prêt et j'ai
pas envie d'avoir à la découverte de man
chinois
oh la la
j'aimais plus parlement flammes était de
l'autre côté si je peux rien pourquoi
pas parce que je me rien et je l'aimé à
côté de vos poubelles à vous mais ça
s'est mal passé des mois
adacore parlons seul pour pouvoir
attendre inkala des sacs ou veuille de
moi je mange pas de pain chaud régime
lavalas banon
poubelle à bron
vous les mettez vous voulez vous les
mettez chez vous c'est tout vous
déménagez vous avez un immeuble bah non
je déménage et alors vous les mettez par
la séduction vous avez pas faire
trimballer tu sais que ce n'est pas de
ma faute si vous voulez jaffe
l'inspection de nouvel an il n'y a pas
de problème entre ivoiriens après
inspection de ckoi la structure vous
pouvez pas vous allez pour 920 vers
l'iss et tout va
quelques mots sur un c'est pas la
poubelle
s'il y en a plein monsieur je ne suis
pas
wafa jackson ont pris
la route mais koné ailleurs s'il vous
plaît à les mêmes d'un vélo là à vélo ça
va pas d'atouts ben ah bon ça c'est un
petit enfant telle enquête
enfin les repas sont des noirs et ben je
vais acheter quelque chose c'est que
c'est un homme et l'enfant il reprend
c'est ce qu'on fait n'est pas d'accord
reprenez vous pouvez après s'être activé
des choses
gilberto chez lui ballast on dirait que
vos paquets de vous
c'est confidentiel on va appeler la
police
[Musique]
est ce que ces ventes est lancé
où il ya du sang qui coule c'est du coca
basset mais c'est mes poubelles je le
promène ainsi vous les premiers oui bien
je vous dis pas non plus pourquoi la wii
on promène de la fin ouais j'ai pas de
chien les gens se promènent les
poubelles
on fait comme on veut monsieur allez
venez venez vous voyez bien qu'ils sont
pas sympas ces champs allez venez les
enfants ont refait la maison
[Musique]